[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti grazie per essere qui
oggi
dunque volevo iniziare questa
conversazione con voi ponendovi è una
domanda che poi è una riflessione se
dovessi domandarvi qual è il vostro
primo ricordo
sebbene l'uomo si è dotato di cinque
sensi probabilmente senza che io sia un
mentalista ma probabilmente ognuno di
voi
difficilmente penserà a un ricordo
relativo magari ha un profumo ha
qualcosa che ha toccato ma
principalmente è un ricordo legato
all'immagine al visivo all'occhio questo
perché siamo in un mondo
fondamentalmente come dire
frastornato dalle immagini un uomo in
media nei tempi moderni
entra in relazione con circa 400 mila
immagini al giorno
pensate nel medioevo le immagini erano
40 ma in tutto il corso della propria
vita e quindi diciamo appunto che è una
come dire c'è una continua
stimolazione oculare giornalmente siamo
bombardati da immagini e io in qualche
modo fin da fin da piccolo diciamo sono
stato appassionato diciamo del
dell'audiovisivo io ho avuto la fortuna
di avere già da ragazzino una
videocamera e mi divertivo a mio modo a
creare delle immagini delle suggestioni
e per fortuna diciamo che sono stati
creati dei piccoli cortometraggi ma
siccome non c'erano i social non sono
stati diffusi quindi diciamo che ho
mantenuto un minimo di dignità artistica
per fortuna però diciamo che fin da
piccolo mi sono avvicinato al medium
dell'audiovisivo e diciamo che non lo
più non l'ho più abbandonato
ho proseguito questa mia passione che mi
ha portato poi appunto a frequentare
l'università e il primo diciamo
per me la prima mia esperienza a livello
lavorativa l'ho avuta con un genere
cinematografico il documentario che
secondo il mio punto di vista diciamo si
basa fondamentalmente su due punti
fondamentali che sono la discrezione e
la velocità d'esecuzione allora quello
di cui vi voglio parlare oggi nello
specifico della mia materia quindi la
direzione della fotografia relativa alla
diciamo l'utilizzo della luce naturale e
diciamo che la discrezione la velocità
d'esecuzione quando si tratta di rito
del documentario l'utilizzo della luce
naturale chiaramente aiuta questo
processo di qualche modo mimetizzazione
io quando sono sul set mi rendo conto di
essere invisibili a nei confronti del
personaggio dell'attore che mi trovo
davanti da quel momento in poi capisco
che insieme al regista diciamo che
costruire qualcosa di importante di
buono
quell'esperienza ritorno appunto la
prima esperienza che appunto vissuto
livello lavorativo e chiaramente ero ma
eravamo due ventenni all'arrembaggio e
giuseppe carrieri quindi diciamo che
anche la la troupe ridotta è un po anche
l'incoscienza ci ha portato ad
affrontare questo viaggio lungo viaggio
dalla stromboli altro di venezia giulia
per raccontare alcune storie d'italia e
lo abbiamo fatto chiaramente con
mezzi indice molto molto diciamo alla
portata di tutti e utilizzando
prevalentemente prevalentemente luce
naturale l'esperienza quando bene poi
questa questa cosa ci ha portato a
realizzare altri lavori in giro in giro
per giro per il mondo è
sempre riguardo diciamo alla luce mi
sono reso conto che è appunto viaggiando
ogni luogo in qualche modo a alla sua
luce seguiamo questo perché perché
chiaramente
la luce diciamo albi gera
meravigliosamente violacea di dell'india
di varanasi resto purtroppo la luce in
questo caso mi sta tradendo perché non
rende giustizia però diciamo che la luce
viola delle immagini dell'india è
completamente diverse rispetto alle luci
con diciamo con questi colori
contrapposti della rive del sarno in
campania
questa resa cromatica chiaramente da
allo spettatore è tutta una serie di
sensazioni che con l'utilizzo della luce
artificiale non sarebbe possibile
trasmettere e
quando parliamo di luce questo è diciamo
un elemento importante si parla spesso
anche di scrivere con la luce quando
parliamo di cinema si parla di scrittura
con la luce e quindi se è la luce
sicuramente un elemento fondamentale
dal punto di vista fotografico anche la
scelta di un obiettivo piuttosto che di
un altro obiettivo
della posizione della macchina da presa
ha una rilevanza fondamentale nella
racconta nel raccontare una storia per
cui se io mi posiziono da un punto alto
del
posiziona macchina frasi nel punto alto
utilizzo un grandangolo e riprendo
questa donna immersa in mezzo alle
macerie chiaramente sto comunicando da
un punto di vista prettamente visivo non
aggiungo parola laggiù musica non
aggiungo nulla sto comunicando delle
sensazioni allo spettatore in maniera
inconscia quindi desolazione solitudine
allo stesso modo
la luce sempre solare quindi alla luce
naturale riesce a regalarci quando siamo
a girare dei momenti di magari dt poesia
di di magia sospesa
nell'immagine raffigurata a destra ci
trovavamo in un campo diciamo disperso
in mezzo ai del comune di di rifiuti
stavamo aspettando che scampate il
temporale è nel momento in cui a fini di
piovere apparve un arcobaleno quindi
capite bene che se avessi ripreso
l'immagine appena dieci minuti prima con
la pioggia avrebbe avuto un significato
completamente diverso
con questo assist di rino
dell'arcobaleno chiaramente restituisce
allo spettatore un significato
completamente diverso e questa è una
cosa che chiaramente
diciamo che artificialmente sarebbe
stato molto complesso molto complesso di
riprodurre
questo questo discorso non diciamo non
vale soltanto chiaramente per
visioni paesaggistico comunque esterne
l'utilizzo della luce naturale in
ambientazioni interne può essere anche
questo un motivo
diciamo di
trattando spesso appunto il documentario
anche qui di immedesimazione può essere
uno strumento che aiuta il personaggio
che in quel momento in scena che magari
è un personaggio un attore non
protagonista a
diciamo
aumentare questo
momento di immedesimazione nel
personaggio
in questo caso avevamo a disposizione
una casa di una donna musulmana
abbiamo l'abbiamo tenuta nella sua nel
suo ambiente domestico quindi non
abbiamo in qualche modo scombinato la
sua
esperienza personale abbiamo
semplicemente ricoperto le tende
ricoperto le finestre con delle tende
abbiamo ammorbidito la luce e abbiamo
sfruttato il muro bianco perché è
l'unico elemento diciamo che riesci
riusciva a staccare il soggetto e
renderlo poi effettivamente un
personaggio del film però come abbiamo
detto all'inizio la luce è una
come dire è un inchiostro con cui
diciamo dipingiamo dipingiamo la scena
allo stesso allo stesso modo può essere
anche un elemento che in qualche modo
nasconde paradossalmente pur cui
utilizzando il la luce bianca una
finestra come se fosse un foglio bianco
l'ombra della ragazza diventa
l'inchiostro con cui dipingevano
immagine per cui non è più una luce
appunto che mostrava nasconde attraverso
l'utilizzo di una silhouette perché era
una ragazza le cui la cui identità
doveva essere diciamo protetta e quindi
non poteva essere mostrata e quindi
avevamo trovato questa soluzione per
permetterci di poterla mostrare in
invidio ancora una volta sempre in
relazione alla discrezione velocità
d'esecuzione
ci siamo trovati magari a ad affrontare
delle location magari delicate degli
ospedali posti dove magari truppe troupe
più o meno numerose all utilizzo di
corpi illuminanti con relativi stati gli
avrebbe creato sicuramente problematiche
anche logistiche
ci siamo trovati magari a dovere ripeto
avere a che fare con delle ragazze non
professioniste ultimamente un processo
di immedesimazione e senza l'utilizzo di
fonti artificiali aiuta il gli attori a
non essere a non sentirsi come dire la
l'ansia da prestazione perché si
ritrovano in contesti a loro più o meno
conosciuti e quindi poi è più facile per
loro ecco entrare e immedesimarsi nella
nella scena questo discorso che porto
avanti sul l'utilizzo della luce
naturale chiaramente non può essere
applicato sempre a 360 gradi chiaramente
però se
determinate diciamo per cinematografiche
mi è capitato di potere utilizzare la
sola luce naturale naturale lo devo in
parte anche a
ai processi tecnologici che si sono man
strumento tecnologico che ad oggi
abbiamo la fortuna di avere per cui
abbiamo avuto diciamola la necessità
magari di affrontare determinate scene
molto difficili da riprendere adesso
chiaramente ribadisco purtroppo non si
vede bene ma in questo from questo frame
ero fondamentalmente in una scena che
hanno creduto non vedevo nulla e con
l'utilizzo della videocamera che in quel
momento stava utilizzando solo
attraverso lo schermo della telecamera
riuscivo a vedere
ora per chi mastica un po di fotografia
questa questa immagine è stata
realizzata con una sensibilità iso di
12.800 iso diciamo che in parole povere
come se fosse la sensibilità della
pellicola il pellicola analogica
un'immagine del genere dieci anni fa non
sarebbe stato possibile realizzarla oggi
con i mezzi che ci sono a disposizione è
qualcosa che diciamo appunto la
tecnologia aiuta il direttore alla
fotografia i filmaker a poterle
realizzare e ad avere una resa
effettivamente cinematografica
non è però come dire l'utilizzo della
luce naturale non è qualcosa che ha
relegato sulla moda è il documentario
solo al mondo del cinema low budget
chiaramente perché pensate ad esempio
nel 2015 non so chi di voi ha visto the
raven altri film the raven hunt quando
leonardo di caprio cercava di
sopravvivere al freddo del canada il
direttore direttore della fotografia ma
non lubetzky decise di illuminare quel
film prevalentemente quasi del tutto con
luce naturale ed è stato chiaramente una
scelta diciamo come dire sicuramente
coraggiosa però è un film che ha una
esperienza estetica meravigliosa e per
cui il direttore alla fotografia vinto
appunto un un oscar per la migliore per
la miglior fotografia di quella di quel
film per cui quello che è il mio
messaggio oggi è quello che cerco
insomma di raccontare quando a che fare
magari con i giovani ragazzi che si
stanno ragazze che si stanno
approcciando questa a questo mestiere è
di non entrare nel panico da prestazione
o comunque di a non avere la
l'ansia di dover pensare ok adesso
finiti gli studi magari però è una
carriera che comunque prevede
enormi difficoltà di magari acquisto di
attrezzature o comunque di approcciarsi
in maniera
tecnologica troppo con una tecnologia
troppo causa del troppo costoso perché
comunque è un mestiere che sicuramente
grazie appunto come dicevo prima a alla
all'avanzamento tecnologico abbassato
moltissimo i costi di produzione
vi permette di utilizzare degli
strumenti che adesso rispetto molti anni
fa hanno un costo comunque accessibile e
su queste cose però ha portato
chiaramente una democratizzazione del
mezzo cinematografico ma allo stesso
tempo aumentato esponenzialmente anche
come dire le persone che vogliono fare
questo lavoro quindi la
concorrenza è aumentata il mio consiglio
è quello che è come dire siamo in un
mondo come dicevamo all'inizio popolato
da immagini però dovete cercare di
arricchire il vostro immaginario
principalmente quindi come dicevamo
prima cercate di appunto
guardare film guarda le fotografie ma
comprare i libri di fotografie non
guardare in internet perché sfoglierà
delle foto guardarle a un'altra riesce a
entrare in contatto con con quello che
voleva comunicare il fotografo e ti
permette proprio di avere tutta un'altra
esperienza quindi sicuramente il mio
consiglio è quello di come dire
alimentare il vostro immaginario prima
ancora che delle immagini grazie
[Applauso]